the nondescript former mining town of
novosinsk in russia
is just a day trip from the separatist
republics of eastern ukraine
six hours door-to-door with all the
border checks
but when this busload of ukrainians
return home
they'll have something powerful in their
back pockets
russian citizenship
for many of the younger members of this
group this is their ticket out
a demographic drift east even if ukraine
calls these passports
since 2019 russia has handed out more
than half a million passports to the
citizens of the separatist republics
here how do you feel
about
another form of control over regions
they already back militarily
another way of making sure the
government of ukraine has less and less
chance of ever taking them back
drive one hour north along the border
and you reach a town called donetsk
sleepy in the may sunshine this one's
russian
less well-known than the donetsk in
eastern ukraine the largest city in the
contested republics
the border just nine kilometers from
here the question is will the other
donetsk one day be a part of russia too
or does it even need to be if its young
migrate to russia
anyway and its passport is such a
powerful tool of influence in the
separatist republics
victor and victoria soon to be united
themselves
think it's only a matter of time
that would be unacceptable to ukraine
and to the west
and overreach for russia too but with
the passport policy russia creates facts
on the ground where the separatist
republic stay
an unsolvable thorn in ukraine's side
a low-level conflict which costs russia
very little
and ukraine an awful lot dynamic sky
news